uh Sam what's up man I got uh I got some
good news for you great click that link
I just put in
there it's uh oh it's your lucky day bro
here's an article in the financial times
called the alpha of ugliness and it
turns out that being ugly
outperforms they analyzed a bunch of
investors and the investors who were
conventionally ugly uh outperformed by
2% I think so uh yeah I I saw that but
here's the problem I'm I'm a f I'm 5'10
I'm not ugly enough to be made fun of
but I'm definitely not hot enough to be
6 foot to get any advantages yeah so
damn
it that's the issue should I get uglier
or hotter I guess
[Music]
uglier yeah when I was in second grade I
really liked this one girl and I was
like um hey uh I want to ask that girl
to the whatever the dance or something
like we had like some party in like
third grade and
um now that I think about it that's kind
of young to be asking girls but that's
what happened so I went up to her or no
my friend went up to her and he was like
hey Sean likes you and she goes um
Sean's ugly and then that was third
grade and then I'm still reeling I'm 3
I'm 35 now I'm hoping at 36 I'm I'm off
that but uh you know still recovering I
would
say our software is the wor worst have
you heard of HubSpot see most crms are a
cobble together mess but HubSpot is easy
to adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better so Anan the
founder of CB insights tweeted this out
I think a week ago and he does really
in-depth tweets where he looks at data
and stuff and he had this one thing
where he said um he said uh I found this
data that talks about how good you look
and your returns and a lot of people
think that the hotter you are or the
taller you are the better returns you're
going to have that which which makes
sense taller people get more get better
treatment and he said no it's the
opposite there's a uh correlation
between attractiveness or I guess an
opposite correlation so between
attractiveness and rate of returns for
investment managers well yeah because
the the investment doesn't know how tall
you are you know tall guy probably could
raise more money but not necessarily
make more money um well and it's uh I
guess is it the uglier you are the
harder you've had to work yeah that's
I've been clinging
to that's the story I've been telling
myself so speaking of hedge funds or
Investments let me ask you a question
okay do you know anything about hedge
funds not a lot okay they what you need
to know is they work really hard and
it's a really intense lifestyle so you
understand that I'm
sure would if I paid you $10 million a
year if you could earn $10 million a
year would you be a hedge fund would you
work at a hedge fund as like a like a
portfolio manager would you live that
lifestyle for $10 million I don't know
the lifestyle but probably not cuz I
really like my lifestyle so I would not
trade it for a worse lifestyle if that
makes sense but like let's assume let's
assume uh 10 years ago would I have made
that trade yeah I would have made that
trade and that's what I think they do I
think they they make that trade earlier
in their career and then they get that's
what they do so I'm reading this book
about Steve Cohen do you know who Steve
Cohen is he owns uh sports teams and
he's like one of the he's one of the
most successful hedg fun guys but and I
think billions is based off of him right
uh roughly yeah so Bobby oxar is off him
but basically Steve Cohen he started as
a uh B he's basically a day trader a
glorified day trader that's how he made
his first couple billion worked at like
billion dollars day trading yeah that
that that's not the best explanation but
but but but basically uh it's day
trading on steroids so it's uh kind of
like calling like a bodybuilder like oh
you like to exercise but it was
basically his own money or he was at a a
it started with his own so well he
started as a he started as a kid 23
years old he worked at like something
that looked like The Wolf Wall Street
style setup where it was like a dingy in
the beginning of that Wolf Wall Street
he's selling Petty stocks at like a like
a garage basically in a small like 30%
operation he kind of started at a thing
like this the story is and and they
interviewed his boss in this book
they're like dude on this first day of
work he came and he goes if I was you I
would do that and make that trade and
the the boss was like who do you think
you are telling me what to do on your
first day of work and Steve was like
that's I'm telling you that's going to
work within a few hours it made eight
grain of profit after two years he was
making 100 Grand in profit a day for the
firm and it was like a day it was like a
day trading firm where they basically in
the 80s it wasn't quite popular to do
day trading it was more so uh hold
something for a long period of time
picks based off the businesses he's so
good because he's a savant because he
figures out some Arbitrage and he's
exploiting that why is he making 100
grand a day so at first it was he
claimed it was intuition which I believe
he claims that he's a bad at math which
is uncommon for a lot of these folks but
he claims he's bad at math and it was
intuition he said I would just look at
the ticker it was at the time it was a a
physical ticker that would be on the
board and it would like change stock
prices and he was like I would just find
these weird arbitrages and it was he he
he would short stocks based off of like
this just changed by $1 I think it
should be 50 c higher I'm going to buy
it and sell it within a few hours it's
incredibly challenging reading this book
to figure out exactly how he did this
that's so frustrating as an answer by
the way it's like you know that's like
my idiot friend from college who's
looking at the roulette wheel and it's
like guys I'm it's got to be red it's
been black four times in a row and I'm
like that's not how this works um that's
very frustrating if that's the answer of
how this guy became you know a
billionaire is good old gut I just don't
I don't know I don't believe that that
sounds crazy to me it's very frustrating
TW TI like Rainman and just figured out
which direction things are going to go
well I tweeted out about it and Martin
scarelli who worked in the HED fund
world has been replying to my tweets and
he's like yeah it does seem like
intuition based more so intuition-based
like when you're playing blackjack or
poker you know roughly the odds as
you're going really quickly the problem
with Steve Cohen is he's never done a
wonderful job of explaining exactly how
he did it however at the age of like 32
he started his own fund he had $10
million of his own money and that's what
he started uh sa that's what the his
firm was called and he hired um a bunch
of people and he gave them like crazy
commissions where you could earn 30% of
the profits you made the firm and by the
time he's like 42 sa which is mostly his
own money accumulates like 10 billion
however after the first like $600
million then it's all not all but it's a
lot of insider trading and they would do
crazy [__] like they would fly to
conferences take the conference speaker
out to dinner at a at a conference where
they're like talking about like
different drugs that might become uh
legal based off of different trials that
the're current L running they basically
bribe these guys to give them
information like this trial's going
really bad trouble for this or um or no
cuz he's I'm looking it up Steve Cohen
net worth 19.8 billion and appears to be
a free man so yeah so here's the here's
here's the rub he uh does get in trouble
for it but after he's worth already
probably five or 10 billion dollars he's
they do it very quietly he's been very
quiet for years building accumulating
about a billion dollars he do later huh
then he gets trouble and you want to
know something he completely gets away
with it he gets convicted and he gets in
trouble sa has to shut down technically
although now it just becomes his family
office a year later he starts another
firm called 72 the guy he did not get in
trouble at all clearly broke the law
many many many many times however as I'm
reading this book I'm reading about the
the lifestyle of what it's like it is 7
days a week 12 hours a day more than 12
hours a day before you do the lifestyle
thing I want to read Martin's reply to
you so you were like like this guy Steve
Cohen fascinating what I don't
understand you know he's basically
became worth over $100 million as a day
trader on steroids it says he followed
his intuition as bad as math what does
that mean so great question so here's
what Martin says I studied Cohen for a
good part of my life and I think these
were the key components as a Trader he
has an unbelievably capacious memory for
stocks capacious wow that's a word I
love that I don't I don't quite know
what it means but you'll see me
sprinkling that around for for the next
three days all right I guess it means
good we'll just say good good or
spacious one of the two yeah so for any
given stock he literally knows what is
the situation and controversy this is a
little bit like how it impresses some
people that Kramer knows most of the
stocks he's asked about they are similar
Animals number two he is unwavering on
discipline and portfolio firm structure
with leverage and a diversified group of
portfolio managers the net result for
investors is incredible other firms like
Millennium and sville have figured this
out too con is also a very smart
business person which most Traders are
not not he can attract impressive talent
because he speaks the Traders language
whereas other similar firms don't have
active Traders managing the company I
think it's a competitive Advantage the
style has been somewhat effectively
replicated by his competitors however
and the Arbitrage has all but vanished
in US public
equities yeah so that's still not the
best answer right that's a very um that
answer doesn't feel good like it's not
giving me exactly what I wanted he he
said one more thing that I think is
great you were like it's crazy that he
was getting you know 30 to 50% Annual
fees he goes remember Mar goes remember
that's 50% net of fees so his fees were
50% so basically he had 10 years we made
about 100% a year it's arguably the
strongest stretch of high returns ever
done similar to Renaissance Capital it's
amazing and this guy he's he's sneaky
he's a sneaky guy he's he does a he does
a lot of bad things in in this book like
okay tell me some of them for example um
you know GLG which we've talked about
constantly expert NK he was Yeah so
basically what GLG does I'm a consultant
technically every once in a while on GLG
so uh a bank is going to take a company
public they let's say it's um HubSpot
for example they want to know all about
email marketing they find email
marketers and ask them about which
software they use they want to learn
about if it's a good company or not
whatever well seep Cen was glg's biggest
customer he spent millions of dollars a
year he would become friends with the
quote consultants get their information
take them out to dinner and be like look
just tell me the truth and I'll put you
on salary tell me like for example if
you're uh if you're on this board if you
work for the government and you're
getting ready to approve a drug just
tell me if it's going to get approved
tell me how the trials are going this
napkin I've written the number three and
as you keep talking I will start adding
zeros go yeah I mean it was basic like
that like that and then they get the
information from the guys and they just
they basically like they they Honeypot
these guys where they become friends
with them ask about their families and
then they get the information and they
bail they never see them
again
sounds like you're dating life back in
the day actually but by the way this GLG
thing is really funny uh so when you do
these calls tell me if you're like me so
I've done a couple of these calls talk
really slow yeah first of all it's like
eighth grade and I'm trying to hit the
word count Yeah Yeah so basically GLG
they pay by the hour you could charge
three grand an hour I become very
capacious
yeah I feel absolutely silly doing these
like I know in my head like there's an
intellectual part of me that's like of
course course $2,000 an hour hell yeah I
should be making that and you know what
this is going to be such this I'm giving
them Liquid Gold that's what in my head
I say that however during it I become
very insecure about what I'm saying and
I'm like none of this is special this is
all so basic what I'm saying and I feel
like I'm a high paid escort that doesn't
know how to have sex and I'm like I hope
they're happy with what they're getting
here for this $2,000 hour because did
you ask him if it was good for
them it's a it's a weird thing I don't
actually do it anymore but in this book
so one of the ways they made like a
billion dollars was doing this for drugs
and they found out to their
investigation that 10% of us doctors
admitted to being one of these
Consultants on some of these networks
and that's only the people who admitted
it and so it was like a it's like a
pretty widespread problem uh my takeaway
so far in the book is um if you're a
white C CRI criminal you could basically
get away with it you can get away with
it um that's crazy so he got evicted of
insider trading and what did he have to
pay and did he go to jail he paid
billions he did not go to jail wow maybe
he paid two billion but he started a new
firm the next the next year right he
paid two billion as he laughed
uncontrollably um all right so you were
going to talk about like their work
culture sounded like um yeah so I got
obsessed with this work culture and I
saw this um quote by uh Keith R boy and
so Keith R boy was at Pomp's conference
and he talks about 996 do you know what
996 is means Chinese work schedule it's
a Chinese work schedule it stands for
9:00 a.m. to 9:00 p.m. 6 days a week and
he Keith stance it seems is he loves 996
and he tells a story about one of his
portfolio companies they just hired the
CFO and the woman who got the job she
was like I was specifically looking
looking for a 996 culture and I googled
and I found out that on your job listing
you said that you guys were
996 and that seems crazy to me because
that I don't think is a lifestyle that I
want and so I was curious about 996 and
so I got down this I went down this
Rabbit Hole of of of working so do you
know the history have you ever read the
history of like the 40-hour work week do
you know how it came to be um roughly
here's what I know you tell me where
where I'm missing something which is
just that when we went to like the
factory industrial thing that's when the
40-hour work week of going into theot
quotequote office the the the plant the
factory became a thing um it wasn't that
way before so somewhat Yeah so basically
in the book sapiens the author
hypothesizes that hunter gatherers you
know we're talking pre- civilization
worked something like 30 hours a week
and spent a lot of time just being idle
with family then the Industrial
Revolution comes along and factories and
machines come about and in the late
1800s early 1900s uh there was a bunch
of surveys done amongst the workers and
it was found on average most of them
were working 100 hours a week 6 days a
week uh so they're working constantly
and it was a grind there was constant
like protests there was constantly
people fighting over this there was
legisl legislation that went into uh
Power in both England and America in
like the 1920s where it was like
government workers you don't have to
work that much we're going to give you a
normal work week but basically Factory
workers didn't get [__] then in the
1920s Henry Ford was like Hey look uh
the thing about our guys working so much
and my company is so big had Ford Ford
Motor Company I I need people to buy
cars because if they're working so much
they can't buy pants they can't buy
shirts they can't go out to eat and thus
they can't buy cars therefore I'm going
to try this thing where we're going to
create the weekend we're going to give
Saturday and Sunday off because if they
don't buy [__] people aren't going to
buy cars so in the 1920s Henry Ford says
the weekend's a thing and that was the
beginning of the 40 hour work week at
least in terms of like it being
systematic Henry Ford created the
weekend he made it like a thing yeah uh
yeah he was the he was the first big
company to make it a thing yeah and he
he made it a thing and what he found was
he did something crazy at the time he
goes hey workers guess what I'm giving
you Saturday and Sunday off I'm not even
going to touch your pay your pay is
going to stay the same and that was
really revolutionary at the time his
workers ended up loving him more he also
did a bunch of crazy stuff so he built
towns so there's towns similar to what
Facebook does Now and Google they
actually like give you a stip in if you
live within 5 miles of the office
because he was like I want you to be
close to the office I want you to be
available when you can but I'm going to
give you Saturdays and Sundays off and
that was kind of the beginning of the
weekend and then since then that's kind
of become standard uh even though he
gave them the weekend people were still
working 12 hours a day so he was people
were working 60 hours a week but then he
eventually lowered it a bit to 40 hours
a week and that became kind of what the
40-hour work week in America is for
workers and so he sort of invented that
what a legend yeah well he's done a lot
of bad stuff too so so I just Googled uh
so Sunday were kind of casually off but
it was like for church but he's the one
who made Saturday also off basically and
then also the the 40 Hour Work Week
versus 70h hour work week which is crazy
yeah and he didn't change their pay he
goes I'm gonna I'm gonna give you what
you want bad stuff Henry Ford did like
how bad how bad are we talking super
anti-semitic so he big fan of Hitler uh
wrote books called like I think he has a
famous book I forget exactly what it's
called but it's called like our problem
and it's like basically why Jews are bad
oh wow so yeah he so very very imperfect
person but that's okay we could talk
about the 40-hour work week which is
interesting um and so that worked out
and that's how the 40-hour work week
came to be now over time a lot of
companies have tested four day weeks and
some claim that it's effective but I
think the verdict still out these things
are really hard to measure and then I
went and read a bunch of studies on
what's the optimal amount of work time
have you ever studied what the optimal
amount of work time is no a lot of
research says that humans can only focus
and concentrate really hard 5 hours a
day that's what some of this research
says there's also a ton of research that
shows that there's like um stupidly High
uh it's like 30% increase of heart
attack blood pressure things like that
of anything above 50 hours a week and so
there's like a huge issue at 996 in
health and I've read enough biographies
to know there's definitely a trend like
can like have you ever heard the story
of like rich people having in the 18 or
1900s having to go to Florida for fresh
air cuz they needed to like relax or
they have like stomach ulcers have you
ever like heard like there's like a no I
don't read history books there's a
pretty like common story amongst Ty air
pollution or because of something else
well they were just like having nervous
breakdowns like it it was like it's like
a common thing amongst the biographies
and the doctors would be like you need
fresh air you have to go to Florida you
need fresh air you're having a nervous
breakdown it's a very common thing of
these of these guys like Joseph Kennedy
um John Rockefeller having to retire for
basically or take a three-month
sabatical because they're broken you
know John Rockefeller at the end of his
life you know what Alpa is yeah he had
Alpa so at the age of 50 he lost all of
his hair and that's a stressinduced
disease at least a lot of people think
so so is your uh first of all couple
questions number one is 996 still in
effect I thought I had heard something
that China was like rolling that back
that they don't do that anymore
technically it's illegal um but still
maybe some people are do but still it's
practice so for example there's a lot of
quotes that says uh like jd.com as well
as Jack ma from Alibaba there's quotes
where they're like like look like do you
want to be successful if you do you have
to do 996 and they like say this on
record in their weed chat talking about
it right so it's still common I think
though there is an interesting point
here which is I think Americans in
particular don't want you want to create
a narrative about why China can
potentially beat us and you say to
yourself like all they care about is
work work work work work and I just
don't want that life and so there could
be this the case of like well they don't
actually work significantly harder than
Americans but that's just the excuse
that we're going to give in our head
because in reality I think a small
percentage of Chinese companies are
still doing 996 in general a lot of the
young Chinese are revolting against that
and that's one of the reasons why you
see a lot of Chinese American workers I
think because they prefer the American
Style versus the Chinese style so okay
so that's what's going on in China uh
Keith R boy says that he runs his
companies on 996 no guy's at Barry's
boot camp like twice a day what what he
talking about so here's what he said so
there's company called Tava which uh
ironically is a software for it's a
service for warehouse workers to help uh
factories find warehouse workers he says
um it's a 996 in the office every single
person every single day it's very uh
impressive and it's not surprising why
that company has done so well in fact he
says this is why the Asian companies
succeed because they do 996 so yeah as
an investor you love when your companies
do 996 why not of course of course you
love it um okay next thing do you
um do you feel that with Hampton you're
going to be the Henry Ford of Our
Generation and take us down to the 5H
hour work day rather than the 8 hour
work day is that a thing you're doing
because I'm trying to bring in I'm
trying to revolutionize the adult nap
right like you know the adult nap is
going to be my lasting Legacy uh when I
die people are going to be napping in
the middle of the day and they're going
to every day they're going to thank Sean
for for bringing this new nap culture to
to adult adulthood naps I've read
thousands or I've read hundreds of
biographies naps are very common amongst
a lot of the people I've read about by
the way so if it makes you feel good
naps are common you read about Legends
Legends nap I nap therefore Sean L
equals Legend yeah you're Indian you're
good at math you get
it um uh do I think that no I think the
40-hour work week I I don't think it's
broken that's what I think I don't think
it's broken like how many how many hours
a day do you are you like actively
trying to work and then how many hours a
day do you think you're productive I'm
those two numbers so like I don't plant
9 to six I don't like that that's I I
treat my running my companies I like I
remember my parents were like oh you
work for yourself you can come out to
lunch with us I'm like no 9 to 6 it's my
job I'm available and I'm working right
so I say that I'm 9 to6 I spend a lot of
time thinking like I literally just be
sitting there thinking writing notes so
if you consider that work I think I work
40 hours a week if you consider work
like typing and actually contributing to
a product way less 10 hours a week
yeah I do the same thing where I'm like
it's awesome I'm My Own Boss problem I'm
an [__] as a boss to myself you know
like I work harder when I'm My Own Boss
versus if somebody else was managing me
but nowadays with kids uh my schedule's
very different I basically do these sort
of like three- hour Sprints three times
a day but at different times so like
this right now is my first Sprint it
basically starts at usually 8:30 or 9
and I'll go till 11:30 or noon
then I go play with my kids for a little
bit which is honestly only like 20 30
minutes but we'll do something fun and
then I'll come back I'll do another 90
minutes in that that next block then
I'll go workout and then after the
workout I got another 90 minutes so
that's kind of like the second block is
those two 90 minutes just split with a
workout and then late at night after my
kids sleep I'll do another 90 minutes
and so I don't know what that adds up to
909090 uh plus the 3 hours in the
morning but that's how much I work which
probably like six seven hours a day and
and by the way I I I I don't I think I
kind of glossed over this but at bite
dance they currently have employees work
six days a week every 14 days and then
uh what's the big um what's the big like
phone company over there is it called
Hawai how do you how you pronounce that
H they routinely ask staff for six day
weeks every month um and they give and
they pay them extra for it right um so
like it's still pretty common but at the
end of a 40 Hour Work Week where it's
been a hard week I find myself fried
like I I I'll sit and like either play a
video game or like watch TV like I I
can't do much I don't know how a guy
like Elon mus or some of these folks
like have in intellectual stimulation
for that long uh I find it to be very
very challenging and and I personally
cannot do it so would I take $10 million
a year to be a hedge fund portfolio
manager and live that life where you're
on call 20 hours a day maybe for $20
million a year for 10 million probably
not I think it' be hard
hard I mean there's a number right
there's a number where you would do it
for a couple years I mean not to put you
on blast but like you're already going
to be creating that much or more value
without doing it so why would you ever
make that trade right like it's not it
doesn't make I didn't say I would I said
maybe I said there's a number there is a
number I I that number has to be pretty
high 10 million not a chance 20 probably
not I I I don't know yeah but that
sounded like uh that that probably not
there sounded like give me three more
seconds of silence and I'll changed my
mind but have you ever read a book like
have you ever watched James Bond and you
see the villain's lifestyle and you're
like that's exciting I want to do bad
stuff that's what that's what working at
a head head fun is yeah does does do
does do it Hoodrat stuff with your
friends that's what it feels like you're
doing bad stuff with your homies and it
that can that does seem you the one sexy
thing I like about hedphones so there
was a guy when I was in college guy
comes into the office our guy comes into
our our class slick back hair and I
forgot his name but his dad is like a
legend in the hedge fund game like he
was like one of the OG hedge fun guys
who made a billion dollars or whatever
this is the son son's got his own hedge
fun and he comes in and he just had you
know when you like you guys were talking
before we started recording about like
the somehow the like more successful and
rich people get the ACT actually the
more like at peace and like chill they
are when you they're they're more
generous with their time ironically and
they're uh nicer and Kinder so this guy
kind of had that energy where he was in
no rush and I just remember I could
literally feel that energy coming off
that this guy was in no rush which was
very different than every other person I
had seen who was this person we're
always rushing from one class to the
next or cramming for finals and [__]
like that like this like high achiever
stress it's just like who was this
person I forgot his name um regardless
guy comes in and he's there to give a
talk and he says basically two
interesting things that always stuck
with me first thing he said was he he's
talking about his hedge fund and and
blah blah blah we're all all kind of
like eating out the palm of his hand and
he's like you know who here would find
it fun to work at a fun like RS and and
do this like make big bets for a living
and like you know 80% of the class hands
up and he goes um he goes okay so look
around here's 80% of the PE 80% of the
class just raise their hand and imagine
if you all applied because somebody had
asked them a question about risk like
how much you know should I should I work
this career ladder or should I try this
thing that's like a little bit of a risk
and so he's explaining he goes look
around he goes imagine of you applied to
this job what would your resume look
like all of you would give me a white
piece of paper with black text you'd put
your little name at the top and then
You' put Duke University and you'd put
your stupid GPA and then you put your
internships you put four internships and
You' you make it sound like you're you
changed the world in those internships
he goes there is nothing that
differentiates you he goes you have a
degree great that's table Stakes like
you know like oh great you went to a
good school like so what so did
everybody else that applies to this job
he goes the only thing I can look at to
even decide do I want to meet this
person is the bottom fifth of your
resume the very bottom 20% where it says
other and that's your chance to say
other stuff you're into your interest
your sto something you've done that's
remarkable or or notable he goes that's
the only way I'm going to differentiate
between all of you that are raising your
hands right now because otherwise you're
all students you all did an internship
you all got a threo whatever GPA it
doesn't matter um that you were on
student counsil like no one cares and
when he said he goes so I would take the
next three years four years of Your Life
After College and I would go stuff that
other column cuz either you're going to
make it big doing something cool or even
if all those fail when you go to apply
to a job like mine I'm going to have
some reason to actually want to talk to
you and that was one of the most I don't
know profound things but like best
pieces of career advice that I had ever
heard and actually changed my I went and
started a goddamn sushi restaurant
afterwards because I was like that's
part of my other they either this works
I create the next Chipotle or it's a
great story from my other section
because he's right like that ring that
that that was the truth was told to me
and the commonality between a lot of
these folks which I I think you have um
they played poker and they got really
comfortable uh gambling so so that was
the other thing that stood out he's
looking around and in class everybody's
got a laptop open and he's looking
around I'm like I could see he's like
counting or something he's like
measuring something and I asked him I go
are you I was like what are you counting
what are you what are you doing he goes
oh I'm looking at how many of you guys
have Macs versus PCS he goes because my
entire year right now is I'm going to
make a long short bet I'm either going
to go long Microsoft and short apple or
I'm going to go long apple and short
Microsoft and he was like I was like
what I don't even know what I didn't
even understand what he was talking
about like a long short sort of spread
trade and he was like um yeah so like
you know my entire like he's like I'm
going to make a $10 million bet or I'm
going to make a whatever he said some
ridiculously big number he goes I just
have to make one bet this year and I'm
going to bet 10 or 50 million on either
apple or Microsoft here and so I'm just
trying to understand like what do you
guys using and why why why do you pick
this and I thought that was the coolest
[__] in the world like that was like you
know he could have lit up a blunt in
front of me and I wouldn't have thought
he was cooler than what he just said
that his entire year was to figure out
should he be long apple or Microsoft and
he was just gonna walk around the world
trying to figure this out he's gonna
make a $50 million do bet on it and I
was like
that's so cool that's incredible and I'm
sitting here playing like poker during
class you know on the one two tables
trying to make 200 bucks and this guy
was like gambling at a whole another
level on one concentrated bet that [__]
was like very attractive to me I wonder
uh which one he picked uh hopefully I
think he had told us at the time I had
asked him I was like so which one he's
like I think Apple because and he had
said some reasoning because of Apple it
wasn't just like apple cuz it's cool it
was something like he was looking in the
education Market to figure out like
basically our age cohort what were we
buying what were the schools like
recommending and then what was like the
he had done I forgot exactly what he was
doing but he was like looking at
basically like he thought that it was
important to know what high schoolers
and college kids and like young
professionals were being told to buy and
buying voluntarily and if there was like
some difference there he had said
something now this is like 15 years ago
I don't remember the exacts but I
remember it being Apple that he was
leaning towards so that's my whole
summary of hedge funds of um the 40-hour
work week um this stuff interests me
Henry Ford by the way came up with a lot
of good stuff invented Kingsford
Charcoal uh that was his doing um
obviously for assembly got side the uh
assembly line uh the guy is super
fascinating a very imperfect person did
a lot of bad stuff too but very
interesting um what do you want to do
all right so I saw something come come
by that um I think you'll find pretty
fascinating have you heard about this
company called law and crime speaking
they were acquired recently they were
Acquired and so this is a media company
that does a combination of like True
Crime plus just coverage of Trials and
Media company started by this guy Dan
Abrams and they got acquired for a
rumored nine figures and I was like wow
that's a pretty impressive exit for like
this kind of like crime Niche media
thing um do you know about this guy Dan
Abrams he's got a like an interesting
backstory no what's he do so he's
basically pretty prolific with these
like Niche media sites so 2009 he
launches something called gossip cop
it's celebrity gossip blog and uh it
gets to 8 million monthly uniques so he
goes into celebrity gossip that's number
one I go to tmz.com every day homepage a
home P every single day every day that's
what that's on my list of things that I
check every morning that's part of your
eight hour
workday well you know you got like the
same the news websites that you check I
just want to see what's going on I check
no news websites but anyways this guy so
then he creates geosystem um which is a
internet site for meme culture launches
that in 2010 he creates uh something
called mediate which is basically power
rankings for media personalities that
one gets to 14 million monthly unique
still going today uh he launched
something called stylite which is kind
of like the same thing Power Rankings
but for designers models writers like
people in the style business holy [__]
Sports grid which is a sports news
business that was acquired in 2013 so
he's creating a bunch of these all in
this period of like 2009 to 2015 roughly
he created all of those that I just
mentioned uh he created one more in 2012
called brazer which was basically
personality like Chef personalities and
um I'm like this guy's like a that's
just interesting like an interesting
model but B like all of those are like
the right niches like there's like you
know missionary versus mercenary people
like he strikes me as somebody who's
mercenary where he's like oh these like
these idiots care about like you know
celebrity chefs all right here you go
I'm going to tell you every goddamn
thing you need to know news information
um you know stories about these
celebrity chefs oh these people love um
you know whatever whatever it is styli
you know media personalities or style or
celebrity gossip great I'm going to
create I'm going to go fulfill demand I
got thirsty customers I'll go open up
lemonade stands right next to them
that's the that's the style of
Entrepreneurship that I get out of this
guy and if you Google this guy and you
click images most people were recognize
him do you recognize him I I he's on
MSNBC he's on TV all the time yeah
exactly uh he's like really goodl
looking he's got a great voice he's
always commenting on like like one
another guilty pleasure I watch Cops all
the time I freaking love cops that's my
favorite show uh and and they have like
a spin-off called live PD he's always on
there saying like oh what she did she's
about to get charged with X Y and Z
right so this guy he's basically a media
entrepreneur and he's on yeah like all
the all the things that you mentioned he
um so Abra media I guess is the thing
that's like launching all this stuff one
of the things he launches so
2016 he launches law and crime that's
the one he just sold it's basically it
starts you know legal news website then
it's live streaming trials then they
have a cable show they have an OT show
they have a YouTube channel they got 5
million subscribers on YouTube they
cover every trial cuz like I'm like
pretty kneed deep in this s SPF trial
right now can't look away from the car
wreck you know like rarely does news get
me but this one I mean I'm I'm I'm
embraced in its arms laughing it up yeah
I I'm just fully engulfed by this SPF
trial and so um definitely there's like
this like part of our brains that's just
wired to tune into the stuff like I
watched the Depp verse herd Netflix show
I don't know if you saw that one really
really well done like the Netflix
documentary on the Johnny Depp trial and
uh you can't I mean you you watch these
things and you just get fully engrossed
in them so he you know he sees that
creates this and they raise $5 million
bucks and reportedly have sold for nine
figures so over $100 million I don't
know if that's exactly true uh three
years ago the reported Revenue was like
13 million Topline and so you know who
knows where where it landed at maybe
it's at 20 25 million now I'm not
exactly sure but amazing exit and kind
of amazing entrepreneur career he also
by the way launched during the time he
was launching True Crime uh law on crime
he launched a Christian TV streaming
service called ambot TV which I bet is
also like that's I love that Niche um
you know which is crazy I mean the guy's
not Christian um at all uh so that
that's very I said do you know Dan you
didn't know the guy you're like he's not
Christian well Abrams is a Jewish last
name and I'm looking at his um um I'm
looking at his Wikipedia and he's he's
it says he was raised in a Jewish family
and his his father has a Wikipedia page
and I'm looking Point Sam um all right
so this what's the Christian show so go
to ambot tv.com and so they're just live
streaming like you know uh I don't know
good old Christian entertainment I don't
I don't know what they it's not
something I normally watch but like you
could watch basically like live biblical
literacy you can watch like you know
inside one of these churches the Christ
Evangelical like Church live you can
view past sermons you can watch
interviews and shows and uh this thing
doesn't seem to have a ton of traffic on
here but let me look at the YouTube
channel I bet the YouTube Channel's n
it's pretty small too so the this
Christian site thing it looks like
hasn't hasn't quite taken off uh yet but
I do like this Niche I feel like this
could be could be successful as well and
then he has another one called whiskey
Raiders a site that uses a proprietary
algorithm to rate whiskies on a scale of
50 to 100 yeah I mean this guy just goes
into passion niches right so it's like
passionate Niche let me create it right
like this is what Ramone did with a soap
oper blog it's like wow you built and
sold a soap oper blog for $9 million
that's like incredible how do you even
have this idea idea and he was like well
I created Facebook pages around a bunch
of Niche topics wrestling politics um
soap operas and others and I saw that
the fan page for these soap operas was
like popping off it was like the second
or third most most popular one and so
then he created a Blog he had never seen
a s proper in his life and created a
Blog where they would write spoilers and
and Recaps and stories about the so
propers and built up so much traffic he
was able to sell it for almost $10
million without ever raising any money
it was incredible but by the way the the
what this guy is doing uh Abrams Dan
Abrams how he's launch he's prolifically
launching new stuff I think media is the
best industry if your intention is to
launch a lot of things someone kind of
described it once where they told me
that a media company is basically um a
collection of different projects all
under one brand whereas a software
company typically is one product with
added features and you're just scaling
it um the interesting thing about media
is when you understand what types of
things grabs people uh attentions uh
attention and how to look at certain
numbers to understand where there's an
underserved nerd uh uh underserved need
and nerd and nerd yeah uh you can
basically do that for any Niche that
like you're like there's it's a formula
um a lot different than software um
eCommerce is a lot like that too uh you
notice that some somebody who knocks it
out of the park with want e-commerce
thing
they know that they could do this five
times over it's just do they have the
energy and the the desire to create an
organization that's going to launch
multiple Brands versus the one but it's
so applicable to do exactly what you did
for one for but there's a problem with
e-commerce which is your cash is tied up
in inventory with media you typically
have more operating cash flow and so you
have more money to deploy to some of
these resources uh how many how much of
your how much of your business so you
have a business in in e-commerce
business how much of the money is in
inventory a significant amount without
saying like particular numbers probably
30% in inventory so not not not that's
not horrible that's that's not horrible
A lot of times it's worse so I would
imagine it can you can go wrong if you
if you mess up if you mis forecast or
you get a bunch of dead stock slow
moving inventory yeah you can that can
stockpile real quickly and become a big
issue for you but also it depends how
you run it so in the same way that
there's a 100 people now trying to
create newsletter businesses and those
hundred are not going to have the same
success that you did with the hustle or
that I had with milk Road why is that
right because it's how you operate the
same thing with the eCommerce you know
with e-commerce if you set up the right
payment terms with your factory like for
example like for us we sell inventory
before we we have to pay money for it
yeah so that's great right negative cash
conversion so once you get set up like
that then you're you know you you're an
idiot if you're if you're losing money
or you're tying up too much money in
inventory right because that's not
necess
uh if you run it well it's when you make
a mistake or or the market turns that
you know you you can get in trouble tell
me about this guy Tyler and what his
post said I I I think I know who he is
yeah so I don't know T about this guy
this guy Tyler Hodge I've seen him on
Twitter he's around on on Twitter but he
wrote a great blog post that I I I loved
um I don't know if you saw this but it
was about
sardines did you see uh this blog post
about sardines so I didn't see it but
I'm pulling it up now by the way the
blog post it's going to make a comeback
I think dude I'm with you I read this
one post and I was like I don't know who
this Tyler guy is but I like him I was
like I like him and I respect him uh one
one blog post could do that for you it's
very hard for that to happen in like you
know a single tweet or an Instagram
story or um a Tik Tok short right like
it's like it takes a little bit more one
blog post you need more time yeah
exactly I think podcast work well with
it but um podcast YouTube videos if
they're longer work it's basically the
amount of uh time that you've taken from
someone like that's how inv post and
he's like uh he's like I'm reading this
book margin of safety and in it he
writes about this famous bubble that
happened that you probably haven't heard
of I guess not that famous but there was
a bubble that happened that you probably
are not aware of which was the Sardine
bubble in Southern California so I'm
going to read it out for you here he
goes there's an old story about a market
craze in sardine trading where um
sardines disappeared from their Waters
in Monteray and so the commodity Traders
started bidding up the price of a can of
sardines the price of one can of
sardines sword and everybody's buying up
these cans of sardines they're making a
bunch of money flipping them and one day
a buyer decides you know what I'm going
to treat myself to I'm going to take one
of these expensive cans of sardines I'm
going to pop it open and I'm going to
enjoy he pops it open and immediately
just becomes sick he's vomiting and he's
like oh he's like tells the seller he's
like hey man I bought these expensive
sardines for you these are no good and
the seller's like you don't understand
these these are not eating sardines
these are trading sardines and he's like
uh so then Tyler draws the point he's
like it feels like this is what's
happened in the last few years with like
um tech company valuations he's like
there was a b like there was a game to
be played you would invest in the seed
round and then the A and you're you this
Company's trying to use that money to
grow it's not really profitable but
don't worry about that right we're
losing money but it's it's all good
we're growing and we got this narrative
and the narrative just needed to be sold
to the next round investor the B you
know the better analogy for this is
crypto well uh I don't think it's quite
in cry there is some in crypto right but
like there's the nft stuff in crypto but
the difference is um to get to the point
of what he's saying so crypto is a
different type of asset right crypto is
not a a productive asset it's not a cash
fling asset so what he's talking about
he's like you would get these businesses
that would go later and later stage and
um each round is getting bigger and
bigger because everybody is basically
it's greater fool Theory right they're
they're thinking well I don't care if
this business actually generates a lot
of free cash flow I can just sell it to
the next to the next buyer and they
would do that they would get to the
point where it goes public uh but now
the music stopped and these companies
have to be you know they're opening up
the Kanas sardines and realizing that oh
[__] these were not eating sardines
these are trading sardines and so you
see a company like hoppen go from $4
billion do valuation or $2 billion
valuation whatever it was to I think
it's sold for like 10 million bucks or
20 million bucks the other day like you
know it's down whatever 100x from from
its you know Peak valuation just two
years ago and uh there's another company
called better which is like a a mortgage
company that's also like you know about
to go bankrupt after a billion dollar
valuation and this is going to keep
happening you're going to see a bunch of
you know the sort of dead unicorns and
in crypto there was a a a version of
this like nfts for example are you
buying this because you love the art are
you buying this because you think the
price is going to go up and up for 95%
of the people 99% of the people it was
I'm buying this because the price is
going to go up that works until the
price stops going up and then at that
point we all are sitting here holding
these like you know these trading
sardines that we don't want to eat um
the difference of course is that and the
point that Tyler's made making is that
what's in Vogue now is eating sardines
companies where if you couldn't sell it
to the next but if you can't exit if you
can't IPO if you can't go raise the next
round well doesn't matter just pop it
open and eat it right doesn't matter
just the company has profits it has cash
flow so we can we don't need to flip
this to the next person it produces
enough cash flow and um you know this
sounds very basic to a lot of people
like the whole idea of crypto is
triggering to them or the idea of
capital and these unprofitable tech
companies that raise money at these
crazy valuations that's just triggering
to them um and so you know for the cash
flow Kings out there this is like you
know today is your day now is your era
you're you're you are now kind of like
King of the Hill at the moment and I
wanted to bring this up with you because
I feel like you have really never gotten
into any of these trading games I have
never seen you get swept up in Angel
Investing where you're like yeah this
this company today it's worth 10 million
even though it's got no product and no
Revenue but it doesn't matter because
they'll raise an a at 50 million I'll be
marked up 5x and then it'll raise a b at
120 million I'll be marked up 10x
whatever I've never seen you fall into
that one or crypto really any of these
trading games you seem to be a guy who
always goes into eating sardines games
whereas I've dabbled in both and made
money and lost money in in sort of both
um I'm curious what your reaction is to
this yeah so a bunch the first thing is
the reason I've never got into that is I
think people default to be being too
optimistic about particular businesses
um you know what's interesting is um one
of the very one of the very first signs
or pieces of writing that humans have
ever discovered we're talking caveman
era they wrote on the on the um they
wrote on the cave that said the
generation after them is lazy and they
just don't care and that's like a common
theme every generation says the L the
one after them is lazy they just don't
care sucks yeah their music sucks it's
like the same thing over and over again
and you said something about we're
caught up in this at the moment My
Philosophy is we have always been caught
up in that human nature doesn't change
we have been the same for almost forever
and the way that we act today is the way
we have always reacted and so when I see
new things I think this isn't new this
has been here many many many many times
and my goal is to find out what has been
here for hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of years and what or thousands
of years and that is where I choose to
place my time in um for example in this
blog post uh she he quotes Sarah G who
says who's like a famous investor and
apparently uh one of her portfolio
companies said Sarah tell all the
founders their job is to generate cash
flow because no one has ever told me
that and that's crazy but that's a
common thing yeah and I was I'm taking
this do you know how to read a balance
sheet or cash flow statement or profit
p&l yes but you know of course there's
there's levels to that game so I I I I
don't really know how to read it and so
I'm taking a my intend to take a course
at like I I want to do like one of these
Executive MBA classes like one of these
fancy ones but before I even did this I
bought this course it's called the 4day
MBA where this guy's teaching me how to
read a balance sheet and his whole
course is summarized in a very simple
way and it's um basically the point of
cash is to generate or to buy uh buy
stuff that you can then sell to create
profit which that profit can turn into
cash flow and a lot of times people
focus on profit but profit is a is a
hypothesis cash is a fact and it took me
to take that course to realize and get
back to basics of like wait everything
is about creating cash flow yeah and he
uses this wonderful example of Enron
he's like check this out look at this
balance sheet they're generating lots of
profit lots of profit Goldman Morgan
Stanley they're all saying buy this
company buy this company their stocks
great at the pnl the p&l will show you
the profit no that's the issue is profit
isn't important operating cash flow is
on paper they were making lots of profit
the problem is is that it was all they
weren't like they weren't actually
making profit uh or they were rather but
they weren't creating operating cash
flow the vast majority of their cash
came from financing activities a raising
more money and this is why there's a
book called the smartest guys in the
room because apparently everyone was
like oh they'll be fine they're the
smartest guys in the room and you see
these Trends today with crypto with web
3 now with AI before that with social
media where the smartest guys in the
room say it's okay that they're not
making profit it's okay that they're not
making cash it's okay that this
valuation is huge but that's a just a
common problem that we see over and over
and over again and so I get suspicious
of all of those things because I read a
lot of history and you see patterns and
this is a very common thing we have
thought this way from the beginning um
so the story of the tech industry like V
the story of all the the startup
industry Silicon Valley is that that
actually was correct like you're saying
it like uh what social media the story
was these companies um you know failed
most failed of course of course some
worked but that's what I think what what
it is the real the real lesson is you
have to know what game you're playing so
for example correct I I agree when
you're playing the Silicon Valley game
the Silicon Valley game is most of these
companies are going to fail or be sort
of um inconsequential to your Returns
the only thing that matters when you're
doing you know venture capital or doing
Tech investing is every year there's
like 20 maybe 30 companies that matter
did you get into them how many of those
did you get into is it zero is it one is
it two is it three the issue though is
that people put too large of a
percentage of their net worth into these
things that's where it becomes a huge
problem and a lot of people do that I I
I don't think that's true I think most
people are not even invested in startups
the average person can like zero get
startups out of this example you could
say crypto you could I mean a lot of
people have gone broke because of it um
and at the the underlying asset still
does not have like a repeatable way to
deliver cash flows
that's that's the difference uh you know
uh there are different types of assets
so for example um you could buy a watch
or you could buy art they're never going
to produce cash flow uh you can buy gold
bars they're never going to produce cash
flow there's different definely certain
types of art certain Rolex Rolexes have
grown no they're not they're
nonproductive assets but they are
Collectibles but there is a history of
uh hundreds 100 years 50 years of repeat
of people wanting to purchase it of
course of course not much not not as
much with crypto yeah and of course and
of course that the of course you don't
get the same same upside because it's
sort of a you know that game is played
out it's more efficient market versus
crypto Collectibles came out so here's a
new new version of Collectibles and in
this one you could be Jack Butcher and
you could make millions and millions of
dollars because you understood that
crypto Collectibles are going to be a
thing or you could have come in at the
wrong time or put the wrong percentage
in of course you could make money and
lose money in any of these but the idea
is you have to know what game you're
playing if you're playing the game of
crypto or investing in gold or investing
in art or investing in watches you are
not playing the same game as somebody
who's investing in cash flowing
businesses if you're investing in
startups you're not playing the same
game as somebody's investing in cash FL
businesses so I think the important
thing is you have to know which game are
you even playing and then what are the
rules and topology of that game so for
example with Venture investing the
mindset is actually I'm going to lose
money eight out of 10 times here and
then if you go read Warren Buffett
you're like oh this guy's the greatest
investor of all time let me learn
something about that that I can apply to
Angel investing and Warren Buffett's
first rule is don't lose money his
second rule don't forget rule number one
if you use Warren Buffett's rule you
could never be Peter teal if you use
Peter Teal's rules you could never be
Waring Buffet right like you know these
are they're different games and you you
have to know the rules of that game uh
in order to play it what I think is
interesting is that at different times
that at different times each game might
have a sort of like hot season there's a
there's a there is a uh there are these
like Windows where certain games are
more ripe or more um more attractive
more lucrative to play but my point is
you ask why I don't do this type of
stuff is I get nervous about many of
those games because I believe that for
example before startups in the early
1900s there was car companies do you
know how many car companies existed in
the 1920s and 1930s tons tons most all
of them went bankrupt except for like
five there was tons of car companies and
it was the exact same thing as tech
companies today and so I'm weary of
those types of games where I I fall a
little bit more into the warrant Buffet
thing where I'd rather have steady but
smaller returns as opposed to Big lumpy
jumps I do get big lumpy jumps but I do
those in things with things that I can
control which is starting and selling
companies I just prefer not to do it in
things that I don't have control in yeah
and to be clear you don't actually play
the Warren Buffet game you play the
index investing you know basically uh I
don't try to make my money on the
Investments I try to be sort of safe and
conservative with my investments because
I'm going to be aggressive and risky
with entrepreneurship yeah uh which is
not what Warren Buffett does he does he
doesn't start companies he buys
companies in in full I met Warren
Buffett in the sense of
um I'll try not to lose money and I will
do I'll take a somewhat more
conservative approach than many of my
peers yes yes yes the startup game is a
the startup investing game is a chasing
and waiting game which is a very R
strange combo you're trying to chase to
find these one these breakouts that are
going to become the one of the 20
companies that mattered this year not
the 2000 that didn't matter and then you
have to play a waiting game to let those
seeds kind of Bloom over the next uh you
know seven to 10 years a month ago you
went to Brian Johnson's house so I want
to ask you about that or do you want to
save it for Friday you can do it let's
do it well so Brian Johnson the the the
crazy guy who I love who claims he'll or
he's trying not to die by decreasing his
age you went to his house you
interviewed him that's going live soon
how was it was there any like
Spectacular learnings from
him yeah going to house is kind of
remarkable um so big house uh not huge
but um like nice definitely a nice place
um walk in and actually meet his son
first so I see his son his son who's on
the same on Instagram he's on the same
protocol as his dad pretty much yeah
rips but he's like 20 like whatever he's
like 20 years old or 19 years old or
something like that and so he's like I
think he's in college or going to
college something like that he he's
super ripped super kind guy and you know
I was like so like what's it like to be
you know eating lunch with your friends
and you've got the green sludge and
they're you know they're eating nachos
or whatever and he's like yeah it's cool
it's not I don't care you know I'm doing
what I want to do it's like you know the
the independent mindedness that it takes
to live a lifestyle of Brian Johnson you
can see like you know from as even just
as a parent how that like shapes your
kids to be a little bit different and
yeah you're like oh you're emotionally
healthy you know I he's like I was like
what do you think would be great out of
this interview with him and he was like
you know I hope you clear up like some
of the misconceptions like there's a
bunch of misconceptions as to why he's
doing this and if people understood why
he's actually doing this they would feel
a lot differently about what he's doing
and um and so you know I just I enjoyed
that got a tour of his house showed us
you show me where he works out how he
where he eats he opened up his fridge
and literally I was like let's see
what's in here he opens up his fridge
and there's literally nothing in the
fridge there is like there is absolutely
nothing there just like one bottle of
red wine on the side and he's like and
then he's like oh yeah um he like opens
up his free he opens up his freezer and
there's like some medicine in there I'm
like oh what's that for he's like oh
that's like this drug that they give to
people with leukemia but I just take it
proactively I was like okay oh cool um
you know you're trying to find Rapport
when you go to someone's house and I was
like so I wear this Fitbit um I'm cool
I'm into tracking too right like yeah I
work out sometimes uh I eat sometimes I
eat chips uh you know like you know it's
like wow it's literally like me meeting
a bit of an alien person cuz there his
lifestyle and his discipline and his
values and his uh priorities are just
very very different than mine but also
very cool very inspiring he's very a
very cool guy so he was um like when you
go to someone's house you meet somebody
in you're off camera within three
minutes you get a Vibe of like what's
this person's Vibe some people will give
you a hardcore [__] off Vibe some people
are kind of like let's get this done you
know Vibe and he was totally different
he was very kind very curious uh you
know want you know it felt like you
know respectful uh very very respectful
very nice what was he curious about
you um well first he was just like
thankful he was like oh yeah the first
episode we did was a lot of fun one that
we had him on a long time ago and he's
like that really kind of like you know
helped get the word out there got a
bunch of good messages from it and that
led to more good things so I think the
first thing was like kind of like thanks
for you know thanks for doing that
um that was the first thing the second
thing was like you know how do you react
to this he's like so I'm curious like
what do you think of this and is this
something you would do and how can I
make this more approachable and like
what do you find um you know he was like
almost like doing a bit of research in a
way to like versus just being a know--it
all like I already know the answer I
have the answer you guys are all idiots
for not following ver you know is having
an open mind on on you know what's a
normal you know a person who's not in
the protocol what's their reaction to
this and did he uh have help running
around his house like doctors he has he
like kind of like number two person she
like helps do a bunch of things um but
not like it's not like house help that's
like his like you know she's like no I
meant like nurses oh there was no
doctors or nurses there when I was there
we went up to like his room where he's
got like all the heavy machinery to like
measure me your skin and then measure
your eyes and measure your ears and all
that stuff and I was like I was like so
you're really measuring like every organ
separately like of course you know skin
is the largest organ in your body it
needs to be healthy and like you know my
eyes are important that's how I see and
I'm like well when you say it like that
yeah sure um I was like so what's the
weak Link and he's like left ear uh or
like one of right or left ear I can't
remember he's and I was like he's like I
have the ear of like a 70-year-old and I
go why he goes from shooting he's like
you know I used to whatever he's like
one ear is down but the other ear is
exposed and so he's like when I would
shoot that loud uh gunshot that I used
to do like you know with some frequency
it messed up my ear and it's very hard
to rejuvenate or recover an ear and he's
like so you know this goddamn thing is
is the weak link did you change anything
in your life after seeing him I tried
his protocol for about 20 days um so I
at way yeah so I ate the I told my chef
I was like hey this is the new thing I I
would like some sludge for lunch and
then I want some nutty pudding and um
and I tried to buy I didn't do all of
his supplements that's the one thing I
didn't do cuz to do his supplements you
need like 65 things that I couldn't even
Source online I was like how the hell
did you do this and did you feel good I
mean it definitely felt light uh lighter
like lighter weight like you can
literally feel your body has like less
baggage on it you know when you're doing
it however I
um I really detested that like the main
meal the like kind of lentil and green
stuff and the one I had the one I when I
follow the recipe did not taste like the
one he had his house so I think he's got
like new versions of the recipe that are
better
tasting that's so fascinating I'm seeing
a lot of people there's a whole
subreddit of people saying they're
living his life well there's there's a
group of people light that are doing
this so uh they hold what's called tea
parties which is a testosterone party so
you it's a bunch of guys they get
together they have a tea party where you
get tested and you get your testosterone
levels and you find out you know do you
need to be taken test or what and then
that same guy has created a meal
delivery service called The Blueprint
delivery service which is takes Brian
Johnson a meal plan and makes it easy to
do because again that's the that's
honestly the hardest part of the whole
thing is like it's not easy to just do
it and there's like it's hard enough to
stick to something it's if you add a
bunch of friction of making it hard to
even do that's that's pretty tough so I
think it's great that somebody's doing
that I think that's honestly a good
business idea because when I met with
this guy I was like oh between the first
time we talked to you and now he is way
more famous and then between now and
where he's going to be in like sort of 3
years you could tell this guy is just
going to become one of the most
well-known people in this world like I
think that his story is going to be one
of the most well-known people in this
world because he is essentially donating
his body to science while he's still
alive which is like just a crazy thought
and he said this during the interview he
goes a bet against me is a bet against
Ai and I probably wouldn't bet against
Ai and I go what AI what do you mean he
goes
well I've basically handed over my body
and the decisions I make for my health
to whatever the technology tells me is
optimal and so if you think this is not
going to work you're basically saying
that science and technology is not going
to make better decisions than the
average human like no way of course it's
going to make better decisions and I'm
just going to do what the data tells me
what the algorithm will tell me to do
and he's like longterm that's Ai and he
goes a bet against me is a bet against a
I and then he the crazy thing by the way
and this is in the interview and I don't
know how people are going to receive
this cuz it's like kind of intense the
interview is a bit intense he's like um
he's basically like I'm competing with
Jesus and he doesn't say that but he
keeps comparing himself to Jesus and I'm
like that's kind of Blasphemous so what
what do you mean and he's like well
here's the thing he's like uh I was told
because he grew up pretty like a very
religious like upbringing he goes I was
told do XY Z and then you'll die and
then after you die you go to heaven I
have a different offer for you do XYZ
and don't
die he's like that's my whole thing
don't die if you're against me you're on
team death if if you're with me it's
team don't die that's like that's how
simple he's boiled it down to and I'm
like well you're still going to die like
the current thing is you're aging slower
but you're still aging and that's where
he was like correct that's currently
what's happened yeah for now the better
the tech gets the better the AI gets the
more I'm able to experiment the closer I
get to just slowing down the point the
the speed of Aging to the point where
I'm not going to die one of the
takeaways I have is what he has done
it's significant but you can do a
version of this where you dedicate your
life or it's just 6 months to something
and like some crazy experiment and
talking about it and you could build a
career like another example of this this
that's way more attainable is you know
the carnivore diet is a thing right now
only you know be one of these guys that
only eats meat for six months that's
challenging but it's not that
challenging and you could build the
career out of that and that is like
really interesting so he's he's he's
spent a lot of money I think he says he
spends two million or a million dollars
a year that's out of out of this world
for just about everyone but there are
other experiments that you can do and it
becomes your identity and you can build
a career about around that Tim Ferris
did that a little bit with the 4our body
where he tried things that weren't crazy
but he did a really good job of
explaining it and making that part of
his identity and he built a really great
career around it and I think that's
really fascinating that's the takeaway I
have which is can you dedicate six
months to something and talk about it
and will that actually change your life
for like for the purpose of actually
talking about it you know what I mean
yeah I think that's totally true and one
of the one of the cynical ways to look
at Brian Johnson is he just did one of
the greatest pre-launch marketing
campaigns of all time because now he's
rolling out his olive oil and he's
launching his like you know blueprint
like supplement pack or whatever ability
for anybody to follow his protocol
simply I don't think that's I don't
think that's I don't think that's true
at all the guy's way too rich to like
become an olive oil salesman you know
like I I doubt know he's got $800
million or whatever like you know he
sold his last company for $800 million I
don't think that he's doing this to
launch a new supplement brand I don't
think that was his intention at all I
genuinely believe that he needed some
purpose in his life and he decid he
found purpose and meaning in doing this
and now he's trying to like just do it
at level 12 so he's like cool you know
for most people they can they can find
some purpose and feel good in exercise
or taking care of themselves um he just
turned that dial up to level 12 and
that's what I see out of him well that's
awesome and you you don't want
necessarily want to also be at level 12
cuz the wheels start to come off when
you're at level 12 and it's pretty
intense but it's cool it's very cool
that there are people who live at level
12 there's I'm glad that Michael Phelps
exists I am glad that Elon Musk exists I
am glad that Brian Johnson exists so
that you can see what level 12 looks
like and then you dial that down to
whatever makes sense for you but you can
take inspiration you you at least know
what level 12 is what I say about those
people is I say I know two things are
two things for sure I'm I love that they
exist and I'm not them right uh that
that's what I know um well that's sick
um I'm to see the episode and uh I guess
we'll end there that's the
[Music]
pod